you want to know what happens next oh
boy if these things keep continuing
i'm excited we got the story from the
daily mail the moment
louisville diner pulls handgun on armed
blm protesters after they surround up
market restaurant
during kentucky derby demonstration for
brandon taylor the unidentified man is
thought to have been eating at upmarket
le chasse
le chasse i don't pronounce it on
saturday night when he confronted the
group of around 50 people
uh no they confronted him he was sitting
at a table eating and they came up to
him
i love how they frame these things they
had been marching ahead of the 147th
kentucky derby over taylor's death
at the hands of police footage shows as
the diner points his handgun
uh footage shows as the diner points his
handgun as protesters
at protesters protesters who shouted him
a female demonstrator urges the
protesters to continue moving down the
block
a police spokesperson confirmed that the
protesters were also
armed there were at least five arrests
charges include
possession of a handgun by a convicted
felon failure to disperse and evading
police according to reports well
i will just uh say very quickly
possession of a handgun by a convicted
felon that's not
that should not be a crime uh you
shouldn't lose your right to keep and
bear arms simply because you've been
committed to crime in my opinion but i
digress
this is what we're going to start seeing
i mean we've already seen
the you know in portland when i think
aaron danielson took two to the chest
from the antifa guy
we're going to see more of this we saw
it with mccloskeys
antifa blm riots they're going to be
marching through regular people are
gonna say enough
and i gotta pay homage to uh v
for vendetta again that scene at the end
of the movie where the inspector is
narrating and he says
eventually someone will do something
stupid and it shows the cop
shoot the little girl who's worth like
wearing the mask and refusing to abide
by the law
it's not one for one it's not identical
but eventually someone would do
something stupid
the the writers will show up to a
restaurant and they'll show up in the
wrong neighborhood
and a bunch of the dudes they're going
to be armed and they're going to draw
their guns
and then one of these riders are not
shooting somebody or the other way
around
someone shoots back yeah well it's
definitely going to get worse before it
gets better
um it's definitely going to get
dangerous and that's the problem but i
don't think
i feel like democrats are okay with this
you know what i mean i think they're
okay with it even getting violent
because they want to show like look look
at these conservatives they're unhinged
they're violent they're domestic
terrorists you know that's how they want
to frame us
so i think that's why we're going to
continue seeing this cycle
well the problem is the people who vote
for democrats
don't pay attention anything oh for sure
yeah i learned that
so you don't even need conservatives to
do anything this is the other problem
conservatives are having right now i
it's just conservatives seem to think
that even though they're being cheated
if they keep playing they'll eventually
win
like something we described yesterday
it's like imagine you're playing
monopoly watching
you know this this person take money out
of the bank and just cheat and you're
like
well as long as i keep playing maybe
i'll eventually get it it's like no
they're cheating dude
yeah the immediate look the democrats
come out and they're like the biggest
threat we face white supremacy in the
far right
and there's like one riot from the from
from the right in
in you know a year or two years or i
mean probably a lot longer than that
and then you have on the left just a
year of buildings being burned is
destroyed to rubble
you had that guy at the sports bar in
minnesota where he shows up the next day
after the riots
and as he's walking in they're stealing
his safe and he's on camera crying
but don't worry the fbi is not going
after those people but they found a pole
rope and a garage and a nascar they
sent out a dozen plus agents for that
one yeah then you get the the capital
and they got billboards and they got
photos and cnn's still talking about it
it's because they have a large base
of really i don't want to be mean but
let's just say really ignorant people
who don't care
right so so biden's ratings are in the
gutter cnn's ratings in the gutter msnbc
they're all in the gutter because these
people don't care
at all they don't watch the news they're
tribalists they just want to fit in
and say whatever whatever they have to
say and conservatives think playing a
game against them
they're going to win it yeah i don't
think so you know uh i think it was
michael malus he tweeted something
earlier
someone said something really dumb to
him and he responded with i don't
understand how people can be so black
pil
blackpilled when we're up against this
and it was like a really dumb person
tweeting
and i my response was zombies are really
dumb but when they're in hordes they
overrun you
and that's what's happening right now
they don't sleep right that i know of
zombies don't sleep i don't think so i
think i think liberals do sleep but
okay yeah i think that the military
industrial complex needs a villain
to whip people into a fear frenzy and
now they're just using this
capital riot on the sixth cnn's
complicit
because trump's gone yeah trump's gone
we're not at war with a with a greater
foe at the moment so they're looking
inward to find a terror i think i think
they just
are trapped in a time warp like january
20th came and then you know joe biden
becomes president and then brian stelter
just like hit an invisible wall
and then he like freaks out and he's
banging like like watching everyone walk
away he can't get past this invisible
barrier
and he's just trapped in january 20th
for for eternity
like that's think about how like a
that's like a oh that's a good idea for
a horror movie yeah
it's like groundhog day some serious
cash to watch brian stelter's dreams
oh really yes gosh i'd be curious yeah
oh my gosh like what is he does he dream
about guilt it's like
it's like it's like he's in the middle
of the night and there's he's in an old
rickety you know house just totally
dilapidated
and he's like walking through the halls
confused there's a thunderstorm and like
lightning
and then like the hallway is completely
black but when the lightning flashes
there's just trump standing in the back
and then he's running but then when he
gets to the door he he goes through the
door to get out of the house
and then pour his mike pants no no no no
no no as soon as he goes to the door
he immediately comes through the back
door back into the house and he's like
no
he's a batman and he's tweeting trump is
here trump is here
and then everyone else in the real world
can see his messages
and they think that he's just lost his
mind but he's really trapped in this
time vortex surrounded by evil trumps
or he's just obsessed with trump and you
can't stop talking about it
i like my version better i think it's
scarier to brian stelter with trump not
being there because he has nothing to
talk about or focus on
ian i don't think it's a military
industrial complex i think it's the deep
state or whatever they called it like
the unelected officials who stay in
power
the people who want but i don't like the
whole deep state things it implies that
the permanent politicians aren't part of
it
no like nancy pelosi gets elected no
matter what interesting she just like
stands there and then just like
stands on the stage and farts and
they're like yeah and they vote for her
i wonder if that's part of it like those
people that are in office for 40 years
are kind of co-opted by that system
whether they're like shaking hands with
the people that are making the decisions
or not i don't know
i think the system is just always going
to prop
up the most vapid and awful people
so terrible i mean kim didn't win no
offense
but yeah the good people don't get it
you end up with people like kinzinger
did it get pelosi twisted like it didn't
always used to be twisted right you used
to
abe lincoln could win i mean yeah but
it was twisted got twisted in like the
40s or something
sometimes sometimes there's a glimmer of
hope
and a saint-like hero emerges we had
donald trump
i'm kidding like yes i'm totally kidding
statements were not connected godly yeah
no i think it's like there's for one
reason another positions are always bad
but
we had it we had a few good people they
just don't make it because you got to be
truly
vile to gain that kind of power i got to
know i mean you tell me about it what
was it like
yeah so we thought we did pretty good
but unfortunately we weren't part of the
establishment
so we didn't get support from the rnc we
didn't get support really from the
maryland gop
party you know they all had in mind who
they wanted to run in the seat and so
when i went the primary
i think they were kind of pissed and
then when a video came out they were
like
whoa whoa whoa whoa you're drawing too
much attention to a seat
that we never planned on winning we're
not gonna win it we're not gonna exhaust
donors on you or volunteers
so please go sit down somewhere you know
so they were kind of pissed that we
we got so much traction i think uh
because they you know
for our governor hogan is supposedly a
republican
and he's friends with the guy that beat
me quiet who is
a very establishment democrat he was the
former president of londonville acp
he was a former congressman in that seat
before congresswoman elijah cummings
and so he is part of that swamp i guess
but governor hogan is friends with him
you know they they all are friends at
the end of the day it doesn't matter
what
aisle or side of the island they're on
they're all friends they grew up in this
they've been doing politics for many
many years and they hold true to each
other
this is why they hate trump correct
trump is
rich but he's not part of that club
they don't like him he's a he's a
bombastic weirdo
and you know i i have to imagine when he
got elected they probably were like
okay donald you got elected now here's
the plan he was like no
america first and they were like whoa
whoa whoa what what are you talking
about
and then they were like we got to stop
this guy he's not in line with what we
want to do
take a look at lindsey graham you know
he walks up to kamala harris on the
floor and he's like what do you do he
fist bumped her or something
it's like i don't expect him to be all
enemies and hate each other i like the
idea that you can
not agree with someone and still be
friends with them right but i think what
you see from the likes of lindsey graham
and people like
mitch mcconnell is that you know i i'm
calling him milk toast mcconnell
he doesn't do anything now that the
republicans have no power
all of a sudden he's like oh i'm i'm
going to fight for all the republicans
oh
yeah it's like bro you had the power you
did literally nothing with it
you don't care it's a show is it
political theater
yeah that's what it is politicians just
go there and they want to pretend like
they're doing something it's almost like
these big tech hearings we keep seeing
where it's like we've had like what
eight now or whatever
whatever the up teeth time that ted cruz
yells at jack dorsey i'm just like
uh-huh
and i i think ted cruz is all right but
at a certain point i'm just like dude
just just just stop you're not doing
anything you can't do anything
i don't care to hear you yell at mark
zuckerberg again it's performative
it doesn't mean anything like the
founding fathers were scientists
uh thomas jefferson and ben franklin i
mean franklin obviously
if not invented electricity discovered
it for our culture
yeah invented it uh thomas jefferson was
a writer a musician
i mean i don't know i know he was
involved with the sciences as well
and those are the people running the
country and we kind of need that again
not to have like
theatrical you know people they just
talk a lot and get paid
what it was is that the government
running
the colonies was thousands of miles away
so they had no choice but to have their
own local governments
and then once you do that they're like
yeah i'm even here why should we
care about what you think it takes you
like six months to actually
relay what we say to the king and back
so eventually just like
we should be independent it makes no
sense now because of the surveillance
state and you know communications and
and you know big tech and all that stuff
they can control
what you see and what you hear man it is
it's beyond creating it's more
about encryption than distance now like
how long does it take the computer to
crack the encryption code on your
message as opposed to how far away is it
being sent and how long is it going to
take to get there i'd imagine they can
crack encryption
and we think they can yeah even quantum
encryption there's that quantum cracking
computers and things like that i hear
i'm willing to bet they've got quantum
computers and can crack can unrival even
like the entire crypto market if they
wanted to
but they just keep that out of the
public eye so people don't know and it
allows them to maintain control
yep so i think that ian has a point
uh because in my i was thinking about
this and i was like well what would it
be like if scientists were kind of like
in charge and leading us and then i
started thinking about
ron paul and rand paul and i was like oh
yeah these are people who like work
out of the public eye who actually have
like in real life experience
unlike joe biden and bernie sanders
who've done nothing but work in the
government and i really think that could
be maybe what we need again
right i guess my question is like we all
understand that in this room
but why doesn't the majority of the
country understand it
that's the part that i don't get like
it's just so easy to see
um you know and fortunately i don't know
if you guys know
congressman jb raskins he was kind of
yeah yeah yeah i'm all about the
impeachment but
a guy read against him that i support
his name was greg cole and he's a rocket
scientist
oh wow yeah and he's like i just don't
know how to really get my name out there
and i was like i'll help you as best i
can
like a very intelligent guy but he still
lost to jb raskins who does absolutely
nothing
and it's like of course these
politicians they're they're politicians
they can't really do
much because they'd be out of a job so
you know it's it's just
it's this continuing cycle but there's
people now that are so upset
you know with what's going on in the
political arena
and now it's like you have all of these
people hating each other before it
wasn't this bad
you know it wasn't as polarized it's
easier to cheat
yeah and by cheat i mean like sock
puppet accounts on social media fake
opinion polls
manipulation propaganda is easier than
honest
arguments right it's really tough to to
have a real argument with someone
it's a lot easier to accuse your
opponent of like you know some
impropriety that they're forced to
defend and then just create some scandal
yeah jordan peterson was just saying or
he's been saying
being honest that's it when it comes
down to it you may not like
the the result tomorrow or even
throughout the years but
it is the greatest most powerful thing
you can do it doesn't sell in politics
no i i think it's uh um
honorable and i i agree with jordan you
know in that sense that we should have
scruples we should
be focusing on doing good but come on do
you really think that the average person
in politics
would agree with peterson literally they
might publicly be like that's
that's a great thing to say jordan we
all got to be honest and he's got his
hand behind his back with his fingers
crossed that's interesting
it is powerful like if you're ever
honest about something you're ashamed of
publicly it it hurts and you become made
fun of and but then you become more
powerful and calm in who you are
but it can also get you murdered and
arrested and like thrown under the like
just devastated for saying what society
didn't want you to say
there are some things that you can't
tell the truth about right so
in terms of military capabilities if
we're looking at war with china
obviously we're going to have
confidential info top secret information
confidential
classified things because if it gets out
what kind of weapons we have and where
they're going then it puts us at a very
serious advantage for
potential military conflict that i
understand you know
that i understand why sometimes we
classify information
so there's a very serious challenge we
have in this country of how you actually
justify the wars we do without revealing
too much that could compromise security
of this country
i just happen to think you know most of
the stuff we hear about from these
people they're like
they get caught lying and enriching
themselves so i just don't believe
that our the political class are good
people and in any right
and uh there's a small handful ron
paul's cool dude yeah his kid's a good
dude
you know there's a few other thomas
massey's cool kelsey gabbard's pretty
cool
they don't have to be right about
everything but it's like are they honest
and i think they are unfortunately it's
like five
people out of five hundred thirty two
people your name aren't even in politics
anymore
dad who else do we have i i don't know
man
because cringe is all right i think he's
wrong about a lot but he's all right
and i i think one of the issues with the
the next issue is you might have some
honest people but then you get some
honest people who are like really wrong
you know crenshaw did crenshaw support
red flags
yeah yeah tulsi gabbard opposed nuclear
power i think they're both great but
even then it's like you know i guess if
they're honest i'd rather have an honest
politician
who's wrong than a crooked politician
who's telling me what i want to hear
well i think senator tim scott from what
i can tell is pretty honest
um i used to be a huge fan of
congressman trey gowdy
oh yes um and he actually told me
because i asked him like before i
started to run i was like
what do you think about this you know
and he's like no
he said i would never you couldn't pee
me enough to go back to capitol hill
he said they're all just terrible people
and
he said you know i didn't get anything
done he said look at what happened with
the benghazi committee hearings
he said we could have a hearing to her
blue in the face it doesn't do anything
it's true no one's held accountable or
was it scott or um congressman trey
gowdy yeah
yeah tim's guy's pretty cool i like that
guy yeah when he when he came out and
was leading the charge on police reform
i i thought that was a very good faith
effort on the part of republicans of
course the democrats
didn't care because they needed to
weaponize this stuff you know
they can't have a black republican
coming on saying okay we'll do police
reform no no
we need to tell everybody you're racist
so we can get more votes exactly
see trey gowdy was telling you it's just
he wouldn't go back it was just no
he even did some interviews they're like
on youtube somewhere but he said
you there's no way he said there's no
way he also has a podcast and i remember
he used to be a prosecutor
and he used to bring the fire and those
um hearings and i remember just being
blown away every single time
and there's something about these guys
who can make the strong arguments that
have horrible hair and he was one of
those ones but i love him to death
he's one of those people who told the
truth and didn't ultimately fit in
because of that
right right and he said it's it's hard
because you're going up against this
machine
and he said i just i'd rather just go
back and practice law
and then i could actually hold criminals
accountable thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time